فعلها اسود الاطلس قميص بيليه يعني الرؤوس
في الدوحه سينما البحر الاحمر في جده ساوث
ستورم يشعل الرياض وديار بين احضان
الاهرامات اليكم الابرز في اسبوع
[موسيقى]
لا تزال اخباره بطوله كاس العالم لكره
القدم في قطر 2022 الاكثر رواجا عالميا
وتفاعلا على مواقع التواصل واحتفل الاسبوع
الماضي بتاهل المنتخب المغربي اسود الاطلس
الى دور ال 16 بانتظار منافسه حاسمه مع
اسبانيا اضافه الى الفوز المشرف لنسور
قرطاج على بطل العالم في نسخه الماضيه من
المونديال المنتخب الفرنسي رغم خروج
المنتخب التونسي من البطوله واتى خروج
المنتخب السعودي من المونديال ثقيل وقع
على السعوديين بعد حماسه كبيره لكنهم
سيتذكرون لفتره طويله فوزهم التاريخي على
المنتخب الارجنتيني بقياده الاسطوره ميسي
كما شهد مونديال قطر 2022 حدثا تاريخيا
الاسبوع الماضي باداره طاقه من نسائيه
تحكيميه لاول مره مباره في كاس العالم
للرجال رئاسه الفرنسيه ستيفاني برابر
وبالتزامن مع اخبار تطورات وضع بيليه صحي
اضاء قميص الاسطوره سماء الدوحه في عرضا
للط بدون طيار وحمل الجمهور البرازيلي
قميصه فوق الرؤوس في مدرجات المونديال
[موسيقى]
وبعيدا عن صاحب المونديال مفاجاته انطلقت
في جده فعاليات النسخه الثانيه من مهرجان
البحر الاحمر السينمائي الدولي بمشاركه 61
دوله وحضوري نجوم عالميين وعرب وكرم
المهرجان في حفل الافتتاح الفنانه المصريه
يسرا والمخرج البريطاني جاريتشي ونجم
السينما الهنديه شاروخان وتستمر فعالياته
الى العاشر من ديسمبر الجاري
[موسيقى]
كما شهد موسم الرياض نسخه جديده من الحدث
الموسيقي الضخم مهرجان
والذي امتدت فعالياته لثلاثه ايام على سبع
مسارح يختص كل منها بنوع معين من الموسيقى
وحضره الالاف من الزوار وشارك فيه عدد من
اشهر المفسقي موسيقى في العالم وموسيقيين
ومغنيين سعوديين وعرب وكان من بينهم
المغني السوري الشعبي عمر سليمان الذي
احيا مؤخرا حفلا خاصا في الموسم
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
ومن السعوديه الى مصر حيث احتضنت اهرامات
الجيزه عرض الازياء الرجاليه الخاص بنار
الفرنسيه لموسم خريف والشتاء 2023 في
سابقه هي الاولى من نوعها في منطقه
الاهرامات بحسب وزاره السياحه المصريه
وكانت دار ستيفانو ريتشي الايطاليه قد
احتفلت بذكرى تاسيسها الخمسين بين احضان
معبد حتشبسوت بالاقصر في حدث فريد حظيا
باهتمام عالميه في اكتوبر الماضي واعاد
الحدثان الى الاذهان سحره ومهابه موكب
المومياوات الملكيه وافتتاح طريق الكباش
الذين شاهدتهما مصر وكان من ابرز الاحداث
الثقافيه في العالم العربي في العالم
الماضي
عالميا تحدث الممثل الامريكي والسماث عن
حادثه صفع زميله كريس روك في حفل توزيع
جوائز الاوسكار الماضي في برنامج تدريلي
شو وذلك لاول مره بعد مرور ثمانيه اشهر
على الحادثه وقال سميث انه كان يمر بشيء
في تلك الليله لكن هذا لا يبرر سلوكه على
الاطلاق بحسب تعبيره واضاف انه فهم مقوله
ان من يتعرضون للاذى دون غيره من الناس
وكان والاسماس قد اعتذر من كريستيان روك
في يوليو الماضي وذلك في مقطع فيديو ونشره
عبر حساباته الرسميه على مواقع التواصل
الاجتماعي كشف فيه انه حاول التواصل مع
كلاس والرساله التي تلقاها وقتها هي انه
غير مستعد للحديث
ماي تاون
فليكس الاعلان التشويقي للمسلسل الوثائقي
هاري وميكن من اخراج ليزكار بس ويسرد من
خلاله دوق وذوقه ساسيكس الجانب الاخر من
قصه حبهما الشهيره والتحديات التي
اشعلتهما بانهما مجبران على التنحي عن
نصيبهم الدائمين في مؤسسه الحكم كما يعرض
المسلسل تعليقات للاصدقاء وافراد من
العائله معظمهم لم يتحدثوا علنا من قبل عم
شاهدوه اضافه الى مؤرخين يناقشون حاله
الكومنولث البريط اليوم وعلاقه العائله
الملكيه بالصحافه وذلك بحسب بيان صادر عن
نتفليكس
اسمك مرس